hello and welcome to the debate on Sky
News I'm Neil Patterson here's our take
on developments brought together from
America the UK and around the world the
Charlie Hebdo global fallout safety on
the streets who suffers and who benefits
from religious extremism and walking
back to the White House what are the
chances of another President Bush the
French satirical magazine Charlie Hebdo
was back on sale a week after the brutal
strike on its offices it's cover should
an image of the Prophet Muhammad in
defiance of the extremists action but
what was the point of the attack the
magazine has printed three million
copies more than its usual 60,000 and
has llama phobia increased as a result
let's bring in our guest in New York
linda's our sewer is the director of the
American Association in your mind what
was the motivation for the killers
attacks what I'm saying is that we have
to get to the root of the problem and
extremism is now you know in whether we
look at groups like Isis and god where
we look at what motivates a young
Algerian French man to commit these
types of acts and again nothing that I'm
saying justifies the killing of innocent
people but we really need to put things
into context in order for us to address
the issue head-on what how are we going
to address extremism of we don't look at
what are some of the things that are
causing those are looking at foreign
policy of the West in places like Iraq
and in Afghanistan and looking at what's
happening right now with Isis and in
Syria these are conversations we have to
have and whether or not we want to
connect that to what's happening I think
there's a direct link to what's going on
I also think about crime in general
right not specifically terrorism many
people who commit crime or join gangs or
are motivated to join these groups of
people who commit acts of crime there's
always reasons marginalization
alienation it's not usually the
prestigious doctor
who is living in a villa you know and in
the mountains of France who's going out
to commit terrorist attacks most often
these are unemployed you know so
sometimes they mentally ill disturbed
you know we really need to get to the
the essence of what's going on and
friends hasn't been very friendly to the
4.7 million Muslims but the story should
also be that the majority of the 4.7
million Muslims who live in friends are
actually peaceful and are not going
around committing terrorist attacks a
week the story has been branded Islam
it's been branded you know this
connection to worldwide terrorism and I
think it's in flaming a conversation and
potentially Islamophobia we heard about
firebombs at mosques this past couple of
days there were multiple attacks before
the attacks in France in Sweden we saw
thousands of people on the streets in
Germany protesting Islam and foreigners
I mean this is a big pot boiling over in
Europe and we need to figure out how to
contain that as soon as possible Jeffrey
I mean there is does appear to be
something of a mixed message at least at
least from from the Muslim community on
the one hand one can say that these
individuals acted and because of their
faith that because of their religious
beliefs but on the other hand frankly
anyone who commits an atrocity such as
this because they've been offended by a
cartoon clearly has something wrong with
them no quite clearly i'm afraid that
linda has brought up every pink and
cliche she could think of and well while
I disagree with most of what she said
she does have a point about some of the
things first of all France does not get
an F for multiculturalism I lived in
France for many many years and it is one
of the countries in Europe that actually
accepts the Muslim population better
than others let's talk about Germany if
you really want to talk about a problem
but no Francis Francis is very very open
to that sort of thing the problem is
that most of these young men and they
are men of course in the case of the
young woman nerves now on the lamb in
Turkey someplace they are French and
they have been to some extent
disenfranchised from the system I agree
with you there are real problems in the
banlieue the the suburbs of the big
cities you find it also with diff
ethnic cultures in in Britain for
example there are real problems in
homogenizing but some of it is because
they don't want to homogenize they some
of the the immigrant communities do what
they can to stay apart these two young
men were French I'm talking with the the
the two brothers and the third fellow
they work they were all born in France
and they associated themselves with
groups in Algeria and took the took to
the streets and two weapons with a
certain type of insanity is it to blame
are the French to blame for not
incorporating them totally into the
system I'm not so sure that's the answer
they were inflamed by radicals outside
of France to react to freedom of the
press and and I think France has
responded quite well it would be easy to
dismiss what happened in Paris simply as
the acts of of a couple of individuals
who frankly some might argue would be
would be mentally ill but as Linda was
saying that there is an extra dimension
there are layers of complexity to this
issue that if we are to tackle Islamic
fundamentalism at its root cause we
simply can't ignore you know I find what
linda has says to be quite chilling I I
find it to be very upsetting and it's
also a part of the problem you know it
is one thing to have a society in which
alcohol is outlawed and violence against
strict laws against adultery and all
these other things are regularly
subjected to public humiliation but the
purity in my opinion falls apart when
women are raped with impunity and sold
into slavery as a spousal war certainly
Islam is not the only religion with the
vulnerable underbelly of vice and
corruption actually far from it but
radical Islamists which she will never
call a radical Islamic she would never
mention that term seem particularly
humorless at impervious to self
reflection in this regard when
ideological purity Linda is forced at
the point of the score this to me there
is little
no wiggle room for the sin any idea that
conflicts with the parting line is met
with instant recrimination and when the
alternatives are obey or die and
difference of opinion becomes a fact
that the factor of violence you got to
be kidding me think about a treat women
as I'm a lil of course all Muslims are
not that way but I don't see Christians
than anybody else running around the
world are wreaking havoc with this
terrorism Linda do you see the Islam
exposed by the two brothers who carried
out these attacks as as on the same
spectrum as the Islam worshipped by by
those many millions who say not in our
name we would not we take offense at
those cartoons but we wouldn't carry out
an attack in such a fashion again I mean
if we want to be real analysts we need
to get to the root of the problem we
need to look at the complexities I don't
know if you guys know but those brothers
were aspiring wanna be hip hop artists
they were drinking they have girlfriends
they had sex out of marriage and then we
see the other side where you see people
and you know Isis showing you prayers
and they're praying like five times are
there and they're devout Muslims this is
not a question this is not a question to
say that there are aren't radical
Islamists are radical Muslims or there
are an extremist in Islam I absolutely
agree with that but my point here is you
want to talk about freedom of speech and
freedom of expression I'm the first
person to protect the right and defend
the right of Charlie egg bow and others
to put out and draw whatever cartoon
they want but what I'm saying is why
isn't the story about the Muslim clerk
at the kosher market who protected
customers were out the store why isn't
the story about Ahmed the police officer
the first victim of these extremists who
the first one to be shot down what was
he doing defending the the Charlie echo
building these are not the stories that
I have to and then I'm asked to condemn
a fringe element of the of Islam which
is which you guys agree with this this
renegade group of people but we're don't
ask Christians to stand up and defend
when a Christian goes out and tries to
bomb and n-double-a-cp building in the
United States of America thank God
nobody was hurt in that situation
Timothy McVeigh was a white Christian we
have a white supremacist who walked in a
Sikh temple in inman in a Wisconsin here
in the US we didn't ask white Christian
or white supremacist or the KKK to stand
up and denounce
violence by this man this is the problem
that we have that we continue to focus
on this element that Islam and the
Muslims have to do this no this to
address extremism we need to get come
into this together you cannot create an
us versus them we need to come together
and address the root of the problem the
root of the problem is not just some
renegade Muslims Jeffrey Wow us versus
them Linda please please the fact is the
young Muslim in the kosher butcher shop
in Paris was the story that story got
widely reported the the first policeman
to die in that attack who was Muslim was
the story that story got widely reported
what I don't see is is Islam standing up
where are the leaders of Islam the
moderate leaders they marched in Paris
that was great but where are they in the
Arab world in the Muslim world
condemning this sort of thing we do
condemn Timothy McVeigh he was sent to
trial and executed we do condemn the
bombing at the barber shop which was
next to the n-double-a-cp building in in
Colorado and it's still being debated
whether or not it was a bomb against the
n-double-a-cp or against the barbershop
the FBI is looking into it that was a
story no you're filled with these
cliches there is a case to be answered
about the aspirations of young Muslim
and young Arabs who were born in France
and their ability to rise through the
economic cycle but no there is no half
condemning the the atrocities in Paris
they that is full condemnation and I
haven't heard that from from the Islamic
leaders I haven't heard that from you
guys out there but still the issue here
is if the our world instead of just
giving surface talk if they really
wanted to do something a very
substantive way they could crush them
because how do you crush them you cut
off their money supply you don't give
credence and you don't give credibility
and you don't give a wig when this kind
of behavior continues to happen and
having these marches and Paris of a
million people wear these world leaders
hold hands while that symbolism is
important these these terrorists are
continue to plant every day and somebody
is aware of what's going on
matt has to step up to the plate and say
enough is enough because it's not these
so-called leaders that's going to bring
it into it is everyday people who are
connected to these networks that finance
them through the banks that's going to
have to choke them to death they stop
this kind of activity at least it reduce
it in a very dramatic way Linda aren't
we perhaps beyond the point now of
saying that these acts of terror are
being committed by a handful of
individuals radicalized coming from the
margins of society I mean let's list the
organizations were already been
discussing book or on Isis al Qaeda we
have in in certain parts of the world a
de facto caliphate already taking place
that doesn't sound to me like the
actions of a few marginalized
individuals let's look at the numbers
there's 1.8 billion Muslims in the world
the largest and fastest-growing religion
right now I think we need to look at the
larger story of the Muslim community
where they are what their contributions
the different societies that they are
from and this idea about condemnation I
mean the obvious you condemn always the
innocent slaughtering of people I don't
care who they are and where they live
and where and in what way that they died
we always need to condemn that and and
and the question about the half
condemnation unless you I mean my friend
Raisa estan said something that I think
is quite profound for those that keep
talking about the half condom nations
and where are the Islamic leaders and
the leadership of the Muslim community
on the national level on the
international level Google I hope that
your own google Muslims condemn
terrorism Muslims condemn the Paris
attacks I'm being just google it and
tell me how many hits and hits that you
will get that's not always a sorority
that is not always the butt media is
always looking for the conflict right
something that tells a story and it's
always includes not putting out the
stories of Muslims and putting out
condemnation I mean I want to I want to
work on the society that i live in
making sure that everyone's included
that everyone has the same opportunities
as everyone else and I don't think that
it's fair to ask for 1.8 billion Muslims
to be responsible right for the acts of
again very few even if you put all the
groups together and you rate and the
ratio to the larger Muslim could you
have 1.8 billion it is still like 1.000
one percent of the people and again
these groups like I
like a guard like Boko Haram it let's be
real political and war analysts and
think about geographic analysis and what
our foreign policy what what happened
how do these groups come up do they just
wake up one morning the al-qaeda just
wake up one morning and say we want to
now be a terrorist group there are
reasons and elements and factor that we
need to talk about that create groups
like Isis and not just Islamic extremist
groups and other extreme is what creates
these room it's not a justification for
them being terrorists or extremists and
if it was up to me we need to eradicate
all these groups off the face of the
earth how do we do that we have to
figure out how they started why they
started and start addressing these root
of the pot and stop saying well it seems
like it's a really big problem right now
seems like they're more than just a few
of them okay great let's agree on that
how do we address that problem and these
conversations are not going to the root
of the problem and we're not eradicated
Isis as a matter of fact what we do is
we fuel organizations when we have media
outlets showing you videos of Isis
beheading innocent people we're being
free publicist we're giving them the
platforms that they're looking for so I
think we need to come together we need
to create some sort of conversation that
includes Muslims and the conversation
shouldn't be what are you doing about it
the conversation should be what are we
doing about it whether we be French
Muslims Christians transcendent now
Linda you've become an apologist for
this let's talk at 11 country Yemen why
has the government of Yemen supposedly
our allies allowed this group to
function if the government of Yemen
really wanted to do something about it
they could eradicate this group in Yemen
tomorrow probably by this afternoon
that's nonsense these people are being
allowed to function and allowed to
flourish not in France not in the United
States not in Britain but in the in the
Muslim world and by yap why are you
calling them your ally that's the
problem with the United States where a
hypocritical government when we when
we're sitting in the things with or even
with countries like Saudi Arabia maybe
any validity to your argument no you
know Linda he needs work seriously on
apologizing to the shame on you shame on
you Linda you're an apologist for these
people and it's utter nonsense you
cannot do that sorry I'm afraid I'm
afraid this is this is frankly a debate
we could
carry on for days but I'm afraid we're
going to have to leave it there Linda
saucer thanks very much for your time at
Jeffrey Armstrong back with you in a
moment
so just two is going to be fighting next
year's presidential election yes I'm
afraid we're already talking about it
could we see another Bush Clinton
campaign John Ellis Bush we known as Jeb
Bush is gearing up and raising funds
well dr. Phil about Mandarin is a former
adviser to President Bush so I suppose I
don't really need to guess who you'll be
voting for come from the election well I
haven't said publicly who in 44 and
that's partly because we have no idea
who the candidates are going to be yet
it's so early on in the process and even
on the Democrat side it's by no means
obvious that Hillary Clinton will be the
nominee for sure and on the Republican
side everyone thinks it's a no-brainer
that Jeb Bush will be it but within the
Republican Party I think there's still
some resistance to this idea so you know
a lot can happen in politics in a very
short period of time so I don't even
know who I'm voting for yet but yes
you're right I'm likely to vote for the
candidate who's a Republican my side
just gently suggest that when it comes
to the Republican nomination there might
be two names to consider at Jeb Bush and
a name that will also be pretty familiar
to our viewers Mitt Romney yeah I mean
clearly Mitt Romney is playing around
the idea of coming into the race what's
interesting is that none of these
candidates on the Republican side are
coming in with a kind of on the front
foot approach even Jeb Bush suffers from
a slight sense of reluctant candidate
and Mitt Romney suffer from a slight
sense of should have had it last time
maybe there's a chance this time and I
personally would like to see candidates
come forward with a stronger sense of
conviction but again it's early days so
you kind of can't blame them for putting
a toe in the water and frankly what I'm
advising here is hurting Hillary Clinton
who comes in with an attitude of
imperiousness of kind of hey it's mine
which i think is turning voters off even
on her own team Armstrong it is
potentially a fascinating battle for the
Republican nomination I'm salivating at
the prospect of a Romney Busch clash I
mean as Phillip it was just saying that
I mean romney does have
form bush perhaps is the beggar name
well you know I don't want to rain on
your parade but most of the media is so
in love with these establishment
candidates and I'm curse that is what
you'd like to see but listen uh there's
the within the Republican Party and even
the establishment and even people who
give substantial dollars they're really
snarling at the fact that Mitt Romney
who had the nomination and loss would
even be considered and run again you
know the Republican Party actually
operates like a hierarchy he's had his
time as time has passed I think many
people will be shocked if Romney decides
to run because if he does decide to run
as an establishment Canada is going to
do more than harm Jeb Bush in chris
Christie and also they take away from
that money pool and I think within their
camps they're going to do everything
they can they stop him in his tracks
Jeffrey man what do you think is the
likelihood that by the time we get to
the point of which they are officially
seeking the nomination and they're not
just dipping toes into the water we
would see both Romney and Bush going for
a min as everyone's basically been
saying thus far there is a finite amount
of money in the world although let's not
forget the mitt romney has plenty of his
own well there was a man in American
politics for a long time named Harold
Stassen who had been the governor I
think of Minnesota he ran for president
ten times Mitt Romney is becoming the
Harold Stassen joke of the 21st century
Mitt Romney doesn't stand a chance he
was rejected by his own party six years
ago he was roundly rejected by the
country two years ago he will not go
through the course Jeb Bush another
story Jeb is trying to deny history deny
his record deny his political stance
move towards the middle to become more
acceptable but that means risking the
loss in the primaries the right wing of
the Republican Party would never go for
him and the country's fed up with bushes
who does that leave chris Christie who's
completely unelectable couldn't even get
reelected in New Jersey if he ran again
Scott Walker from Ohio who may be in
with a shot but they tried to impeach
him George Pataki's on the list former
governor of New York a forgotten man and
then you've got the clown car Brigade
you've got Rick Santorum and Mike
Huckabee Rick Perry Ted Cruz boy that
would be great I mean I would I would
actually send money to Ted Cruz campaign
because then Hillary would win
70 states and there are only 50 John
McCain is trying to push Lindsey grab
another great idea for the Democrats
rand paul rand paul's trying to move to
the middle two and my bed is my bet is
if there's an outside candidate Rand
Paul will be it so Hillary ill only win
60 states the New York Times says is a
possible of 26 candidates right now who
are dipping their toes into the water
the Republicans be careful what you wish
for guys have won both houses of
Congress and they will proceed to do
what the republicans always do screw
that up so that by the time we get to
the primaries in the summer of 2016
whether a not Donald Trump is part of
the group they will self-destruct so all
I have to say is go MIT go Ted Cruz
can't wait for it Phillip I have to give
you the opportunity to to respond to
Jeffrey there on given your association
with the clan is America sick of the
bushes you know I don't think it as as
sick of it as the media would like to
think so and I think that Jeb Bush will
prove to be he's more conservative than
people give him credit for and I don't
think he'll have as hard a time with the
far right as people say but but the real
issue is globally we are seeing general
public saying I'm tired of the old gang
I want somebody new who can fix problems
and therefore there's got to be a
premium on all these candidates that
nobody talks about and hasn't really
heard of I think the outsider odds are
very high in this particular election
and let's not forget the last few
presidents were similar I mean Bill
Clinton came out of nowhere and
basically one because all the
establishment figures on the Democrat
side said this race is too hard to win
and they dropped out it was like the
water boy on the baseball team said let
me have a go President Obama arguably
came out of nowhere and I don't see why
we can't get another candidate like that
and if anything I think Jeb Bush is
going to define what the issues are at
one end of the spectrum and I think Ted
Cruz is going to have a voice in this
and we'll define the issues at the other
end
and the candidate that probably comes
forward the strongest will be a third
person who establishes what's the right
place to be between those two guys arm
strongly given with her two terms of
Obama I mean do you see the Republicans
possibly because of that Cruz effect
whatever the Ken whoever the candidate
is do you see them being pushed further
to the right than perhaps ever before I
think it's obvious by the coop they
tried to pull to make sure that Boehner
did not win the speakership on the first
ballot that obviously Boehner and Mitch
McConnell has more respect within their
party because they see them as consensus
builder builders and they work we're
very close they work very well with the
president even though they don't get
enough credit for it and look you say
whatever you want to say about Jeb Bush
but look I I know people are probably
saying we don't want a monarchy here but
the bottom line Americans are really
desperate for leadership on a farm front
they're desperate foot on the domestic
front and if Jeb Bush has the right
ideas and the right leadership and he
can sort of get his issues together on
immigration and common core and shoulder
his base with conservatives look you
cannot kind of my I think the fact that
he is a bush I'm no one's going to
question his ability to lead and his
ideas I don't think you can count any
when I I think though that this is an
opportunity for a dark hearts to rise I
think the Republicans have learned from
the past when they did not have the
power and they were out in that Valley
and I think they will come together and
they will not do what Jeffords trying to
indicate and they will show leadership
they will work with the president they
will get things done for the American
people and I think if they do this if
they deliver through substance and not
do rhetoric I think it gives the
Republicans a great chance to do
something is that rarely happens in
history where they control all three
chambers the the the White House and
Congress Jeffrey well they say hi to an
abstract on your strong the height of
their the height of their leadership was
Mitch McConnell coming into office
saying my job is to make sure this is a
one-term president that's real
leadership after the actual history you
keep going back to that situation we're
beyond damage but give us something new
we felt that before please come on give
us a news reel it's mitch mcconnell what
is he standing coming majority what he
he said bit since we come in my Jordan
leader you can't even tell us cuz you're
so stuck in the past Chuck he's gonna
push through he's gonna push through all
the social legislation that none of
America wants let's talk about Jeb Bush
Jeb Bush and his leadership Jeb Bush
could not even win Florida in a
presidential election that's what they
think of his leadership down there I
think you're right that the dark horse
has a real shot at this but he's gonna
have to come up pretty soon and make
himself known because the main
candidates Christie and Walker and bush
and Romney are absolutely gonna
self-destruct there is no doubt about
that so a dark horse yeah sure maybe but
here's my question is why is it that all
the polls show the American public wants
bipartisanship and yet it seems to be
the one thing that neither side can
deliver and the question is is there a
place for candidate who really supports
bipartisanship or does that kill them in
their effort to win got to leave it
there at dr. Philip amalgam and
definitely Robinson and Armstrong
Williams as always thanks very much for
your time well that is your lot for this
edition of the debate until next time
goodbye
you